ce dernier repique us
c'est gentil ça me fait plaisir vous
sait comment ça va les amoureux on va
bien la petite fessée nuit surtout quand
bah justement moi ça va pas super c'est
pour ça que voulez vous voir
à l'horizon je dois l'oral je voulais
parler journée puisque vous voulez c'est
ici qu'est ce que tu voulais me dire
j'ai vu le médecin et ça va pas
s'arranger
je suis en train de perdre la partie et
je voulais te demander un service au
vent
oui mais bien sûr truc que tu alors je
parte
est ce que tu pourrais me sucer la [ __ ]
ouais ouais voilà c'est fait le bilan de
ma vie j'ai envie de partir avec un
regret et je me suis rendu compte quand
je vous ai présenté tous les deux
j'étais pas mal chaussures loi en fait
non matin il est hors de question
catésis la vie d'un enfant pas comme ça
mais je suis en train de mourir c'est
seulement ça n a pas de succès on prend
du recul de seconde est ce qu'elle va
pas tu souhaites excusez moi est ce que
vous pouvez arrêter de parler comme si
j'étais pas là toi tu peux arrêter de
décider des trucs pour moi deux secondes
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes tu vas
pas le suicide mais j'ai jamais dit que
je voulais lui sucer la [ __ ] je dis que
tu n'as pas décider des choses pour moi
bon bah super à l'aise puisque désolé de
vous avoir dérangé mais un rêve de jouer
au con j'ai jamais dit que j'allais le
sucer c'est exactement de cela dont je
te parlais dans la voiture lorsque dans
la voiture on parler de ta liberté sucer
mes potes maintenant on parlait du fait
que tu décides des choses à ma place
sans le consulter
comme le chalet en décembre ok donc
partir dans les alpes et sucé julien
c'est la même chose comme pas tout ce
qu'ils ont des sens moi mais tu t'es
forme tout métro pont tu sais quoi je
suis pas ta chose un t'appartient pas
c'est ce que je le suis ici je veux as
tu veux le succès est donc j'ai pas dit
ça
excuse moi mais l instant tu viens de
dire que je sais quoi je vais les sucer
manquantes regardons bien dans les yeux
pour tu comprennes que je fais ce que je
veux ma vie alors en fait moi j'avais
plutôt de penser qu'on serait que tous
les deux puisque je suis pas très raison
tu veux juste le sucès jerry's ou jade
et les doubiens métier tentant mais
regarde toi tu fais pitié été
complètement flippé tu veut tout
contrôler c'est quoi tu me saoules et
julien sorte habite nous montons but
page
mais s'il me fathi julien les sortes
abidal et sort là parce que c'est un
centre puissant qui décide
oh et puis on prêtait baiser aussi tant
qu'on y est ça fait des mois personnes
obèses à sa palette et compagnie c'est
moi tout va bien si monsieur jaubert
vous leur avez annoncé la nouvelle
j'allais le faire si geri qassam suisse
est devant lui
[ __ ] c'est trop bien le cancer
vous avez aimé ce sketch venez voir le
golden moustache au au grand rex le 22
juin
au programme nous meilleurs sketches des
inédits et du stand-up
allez viens on va rire c'est dur vous
savez je suis une femme j'ai des besoins
je ne comprendrais jamais mon père